you see here the Bionic kangaroo which  is inspired by the real natural role  model my name is Elias Kalugin  industrial designer and I work at pesto  pesto actually produces in develops  products for the industrial automation  the kangaroo for us is a very  interesting and synthetic a role model  because it's very inner energy efficient  it's able to store the energy of the  landing phase in the achilles tendon and  can retake it for the next jump also  it's able to get faster and faster  without using more energy champing is  really something very complicated it  needs a lot of control we're using a  Maya interface which is a gues Chur  device which can be mounted on the arm  and using EMG signals we are able to  detect several gases those sketches are  centered then to the kangaroo a  Bluetooth the robot is not for sale it's  a future concept at the moment we try to  learn from nature and to bring our  knowledge and our products we usually  sail